while I have you me okay we have an
article that just came out recently the
the headline on Business Insider was the
Navy cryptically says it has top secret
UFO briefings that would cause quote
exceptionally grave damage to US
national security
if published so we have lights that
evidently defy the laws of physics but
they won't release this video because it
is classified top secret in response to
the Freedom of Information request that
was submitted so what's your question
the question is our aliens Rico and do
we already know that I'm not authorized
to respond to that so how many times I
have to tell people this I don't know
what is the U stand for in UFO
unidentified so we don't know what it is
the universe brim is with mysteries
daily yeah and just because you don't
know what it is doesn't then mean it's
intelligent aliens visiting from outer
space it doesn't then mean that not only
that do you really need the Navy to take
video of the sky okay a billion photos
and videos are uplifted to the Internet
every day you don't need the military to
do this we could do it where's the yeah
so there might be some video some lights
we don't understand I'm okay with that
maybe they are aliens I just want better
evidence than that race if there's
aliens I want some really good evidence
they're aliens like how about the alien
itself
give me some aliens right you got a
camera you got a video okay okay did you
just get abducted show me and I'm
walking towards you you can live stream
the encounter so that they can't zap it
and prevent and prevent the chip from
retaining its memory lock that stream
the antlion walking towards you where's
all that footage and how did the alien
so quite
just visit for a second like well that's
the shy maybe they only just shy when
they only want to reveal themselves to
the US Navy I mean I've seen Facebook
people can't visit Greece without
posting 7000 pictures of it aliens are
gonna visit earth and not post about it
you would have photos of every possible
angle of that walkin alien coming down
the street selfies alien selfies right
right so I'm just maybe there are aliens
but lights in the sky you can't explain
are not evidence for that they're
evidence for something that you don't
know what it is and I'm cool with that
as the German poet Rainer Maria Rilke II
once said learn to love the questions
themselves if you must have an answer
and that answer must be they're
intelligent aliens okay but as a
scientist I need better evidence than
that
I need Will Smith and and and yeah
welcome to earth boom budget drags the
alien to a place where you couldn't you
know talk about it look at it to take it
in to town hall whatever okay here let
me let me let me send a message to
aliens okay this is gonna get out okay
good aliens when you visit earth try not
to visit during comic-con no one will
notice you please come at some other
time of year okay but also have a very
distorted view of Earth they'll be like
they all dressed like superheroes and
none of them mate how did this species
replicate I don't understand they do
mate they just don't make movies about
it all right all right so that's that's
my reply to this are you okay with that
I'm okay with that
all right Harrison Harrison Greenvale
read the newspaper
aughh start off camera cuts i unzip
myself
[Laughter]
[Music]